my name's anthony padilla and i spent a
day with autosexuals we'll uncover the
truth about how it feels to get
butterflies in their stomach when
thinking about themselves or visualizing
themselves and how autosexuality can go
far beyond simply being sexually
attracted to oneself resulting in one of
the guests in this video falling in love
with and even getting engaged to marry
himself by the end of this video we'll
find out if identifying as autosexual
has enabled these guests to unlock a
level of self-confidence and self-love
far beyond what most people allow
themselves to experience or if the
unprovoked attacks and hate that they
receive claiming that they're just
narcissistic attention seekers made them
regret publicly embracing this label in
the first place
are you familiar with autosexuals i
heard a few stories but i'm not familiar
with it i'm not gonna lie when i heard
autosexual i just thought it was people
who were the autobots transformers yeah
yeah that's really what i thought at
first but anyways before i make fun of
these people uh let me actually give
them a chance because
and i started laughing immediately so
i'm just about to put the dick in that
pipe hey look
that's a muffler i'm about to exhaust
your exhaust
right there let's let let's unclog these
engines let's get it hello gia hello
okay
okay
i gotta say something
all these people with funky ass
sexualities that are like demisexual all
the other [ __ ] okay yeah i don't
know why but they always got a weird
look uh pale faces lots of makeup
piercings in random places colorful hair
weird haircut i don't know about y'all
but i noticed that everybody who's got
these weird new sexualities i've never
heard of always look a little special am
i crazy i mean that's pretty normal she
has pretty normal
she's just that she looks like she's
from the addams family yeah she just got
black but you know with a few extra
sisters
inside but anyways let's go
alex hi
so far so good
kenzie hi anthony how are you jesus
christ
sorry
i said that wow i said that out loud wow
okay i'll edit that out
no no no no though i wasn't back to yeah
yeah yeah
how do you define autosexuality it's
self-love it's uh seeing yourself in the
mirror and being able to not only love
yourself but be aroused by yourself i
prefer
self-pleasure over sex with like
partners or anyone else in the same way
i would be attracted to a lover i am
attracted to myself it goes beyond
sexual attraction to yourself it is also
romantic yes very much so is it the
exact same thing as
interacting with like a potential suitor
i look at myself the way that like other
people would look at their partners
stand there nude in the mirror admiring
your body and saying
bangable yes like that i love looking at
myself in the mirror and when i spend
time by myself i often feel like i'm
spending time alone with a crush i just
look in the mirror and i like what i see
i may even look in the mirror while
doing my scent my essential acts with
myself
why do you think
autosexuality is seen as narcissistic
while the self-love movement
is seen as something empowering and
encouraging the only difference is that
it's a sexuality i feel like it's their
own self-esteem or their opinion of
themselves that may guide them into
thinking well you have this inflated ego
you you're narcissistic so i think it's
really true to heart a projection on
themself where is that line drawn
between
encouraging someone to love themselves
and saying you that person is
narcissistic for loving themselves a
little bit too much narcissism tends to
be psychological and fit and mental
whereas autosexuality tends to be like
emotional and personal
[ __ ]
madame
obama
you use synonyms
now i will not go out of my way and say
listen you got this mental health issue
or you're narcissistic that's not
because i don't know okay i don't know
enough about clinical narcissism to know
but based off the definitions you said
you said the same [ __ ] thing you just
use synonyms yes
you look at yourself and you find
yourself hot for you you don't sit there
and go everyone around me knows i'm hot
that to me screams more of the
narcissistic mindset no one in the world
could know that you find yourself
sexually attractive
if you didn't choose to talk about it
yes exactly narcissists don't talk about
it like that it's not that oh it's not
like that spoken
that's not what happens you're basing
yourself of you're basing yourself uh
the the the the
you're basing yourself on the definition
of narcissist throughout movies and
media that's not what really happens
but whatever
oh my god
i've done an episode on asexuality does
autosexuality fall under the asexuality
spectrum it is considered asexual the
difference is you have the people that
are sex repulsed which most asexuals
find themselves kind of on that side i'm
not to the point where i will never have
sex with someone else but i just don't
prefer it
so you're not asexual
all right
what
i feel like when i watch live let's just
be more and more confused
that's my face normally when people tell
me like yeah i'm demisexual i'm just
like
okay
you know what's funny
because i don't know where this video is
going to go but i think i have some idea
remember we talked about this last time
where we talking about everybody's
coming out with these new sexualities
that's fine right i'm sapiosexual what
does that mean well i'm attracted to
people's intelligence like and for me
it's hard to be aroused unless i know
somebody and like their mind stimulates
me
well you know maybe it's because i grew
up and everyone's just like yeah you
know i like people with personalities no
i'm sapiosexual okay i'm i'm demisexual
what does that mean i need to be
attracted to someone's personality and
soul before i can be sexually aroused
okay it's like
like most women i know maybe maybe i
missed something
maybe i miss something what do you think
is the need for all these titles people
want to belong to somewhere even if it's
to not belong somewhere
super weird i know i told you human
beings are weird okay people want to
belong somewhere even if it means not
belong somewhere because not belonging
somewhere is actually putting a
netiquette or putting a tag on what you
are and then therefore belonging
somewhere super weird super
contradictory but i believe that's what
it is all right it's like outcasts
basically yeah they want to belong to
the outcasts yeah exactly because even
when you don't belong you still belong
to that the outcast
it feels good to understand people
like to find people that really are
connected with you and if it doesn't
feel good to feel
if it doesn't feel good to find people
that are like you being an outcast
therefore you're a hipster all right
personally i don't give a [ __ ] about
what you which is your sexuality is if
i'm not trying to if i'm not trying to
[ __ ] you it doesn't matter
but hey
hey if that's what you do you want to be
like yeah i'm [ __ ] i want to [ __ ] me
in
do you
do you
that's your thing that's your thing so
is it acceptable for me to say like i'm
a boobie sexual
yeah
like i'm super attracted to women's
teams like no no it's not normal i don't
just like sucking on like biting them
looking underneath all that stuff does
that make me a booby sexual
like more than the average person like
i'm obsessed with boobies i guess okay
are [ __ ] booty sexuals
which sounds okay but i was super gay
yeah like they're obsessed with ass
my question what does your preference
become a sexuality
i would point your preference because it
becomes an identity because now it's
like it's not just it's your identity
it's not just a preference it's just
you're making it an identity you claim
you are like the hope it's your whole
being yeah that's me you know what i
mean
[ __ ] started with homosexual
cocaine oh you're into men cool makes
sense
okay
bye
okay
and then after that i just i don't know
it kind of i kind of got lost in
everything yeah asexual i can understand
too like you're just not attracted
don't want it that's okay okay make
sense i'm attracted to
smart i'm like
i'm attracted to women with nice feet
footy sexual
and then and then there's people and
there's people that just and there's
people that just like put a lot of
different categories and sub categorize
just to be more specific
i'm etero romantic
uh sapiosexual i'm like
you like smart dudes
my suspicion is that these are dull
people and they try to look for things
externally to make them special it's a
possibility
because because there's an overlap
between trying to look different try to
act different and try to be different
you get what i'm saying like even their
whole look it's like i'm doing this i'm
doing all this extra stuff to peacock
yeah right i'm peeking with titles i'm
peacocking with things that are easily
accessible i can cut my hair tomorrow
i don't i don't i don't got gotta be in
top shape i don't gotta get a fortune
500 company which takes i don't do none
of that if i want a peacock in this room
realm i gotta just dress crazy and just
say grace
cause those two take the least amount of
effort
fair right there's nothing special about
me but i'm going to say that this thing
about me that's a little bit peculiar is
actually what's most special i can't i
can't attest to it i can't or different
kind of thing every i really don't i
would have liked the way more if y'all
[ __ ] cars then i would have been like
i accept
there's some sexy cars out there yeah if
you get on a stick shift and put it
inside you and do stuff hey
you're autosexual okay let's get it
but
otherwise i'm like
what nothing
there's definitely been people who've
like said stuff like that oh stick shift
let me write your stick yeah okay so
if they've said it somebody's done it
yeah okay i know people i'm pretty sure
it's out there i've known for a long
time that i've been able to experience
love desire and pleasure with other
people but the second that you surpass
you know second base and you're
migrating on to third my brain tends to
um shut down so you're fine with making
out touching good feeling the moment
you're about to bang then your brain
shuts off but you're able to do all the
other stuff
boom i don't think that's a sexuality
you just might need therapy
you might have mental blocks that maybe
make it hard for you like there's a
several reasons but i think it's crazy
it's not like i'm completely not
interested in people i like them
fondling me i like fingers inside i like
whatever the moment is penetration
penetration then i freak out it's like
well maybe you got some mental blocks
it's not just have to be a sexuality
you know people are really attracted to
men with money remember we said currency
sexual i like that okay right no not
gold diggers no no no it's a new
sexuality they're currency sexual i mean
they're attracted only to men with a
tremendous amount of wealth a lot of
that makes sense like rough
currency section that makes a lot of
sense
you just invented something
to what degree do you prefer
self-pleasure over pleasure with others
out of the entire month i usually only
have sex like once or twice but then
with myself it's pretty healthy pretty
regular so you don't just [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
i think you're addicted to porn
that's just my thing but whatever no
she's she's banging she's she's
masturbating to herself yeah to her to
herself yeah
she literally looks at herself in fear
then
that's how you mess nevermind me never
mind
i definitely i curve my back and i hunch
forward curve oh yeah you got to get a
good you got to get a bad posture when
you do it too much information
anyways um okay maybe not i don't know
much because she likes
herself she likes masturbating and she
likes [ __ ] other people doesn't
matter i mean i get that sometimes i
don't want to bang my partner either
i'll be just tuning one out but abba are
you thinking about yourself when you do
it no okay i think it's probably where
we differentiate
it doesn't matter
everyone's calling this narcissism i'm
like i don't know it's narcissism but it
is kind of weird it is very
self-absorbed almost some people were
calling it oh no this is just self-love
they just care about themselves so i'm
like bro stop kidding you don't have to
do it everything's so [ __ ] hippie
they were they were talking about whole
ass relationship marrying themselves uh
no that's not just self-care there's
there's levels to this [ __ ] that's not
that level hey man it's like i'm not
completely turned off on it it's just
not that common to find me actually
wanting it with other people is it fluid
is it
some days it's more than
the other or is it pretty consistent for
me i would say is pretty fluid like i
have some weeks where i have pretty
regular sex with my partners and then
other times where i go several months
without wanting right anyone else
whole fluid word sometimes gets so
overused i think it's funny it's like
some days is it this yeah like every
human some days you want to [ __ ] some
days you don't you're not fluid because
you're asexual on mondays and tuesdays
because you didn't feel like [ __ ] and
then you want to [ __ ] on the weekend
doesn't make you fluid yeah
yo you don't want to [ __ ] every day when
that means you're fluid yeah
now they're taking the fluid taking the
piss you know a little you're taking the
fluid
pulse
do you remember the moment when you
realized that the attraction that you
felt
for yourself was different than the way
that others were attracted to themselves
it started when i was seven and i looked
at myself in the mirror after i had
showered and i noticed i really liked
what i saw i discovered i was autosexual
before i realized i was attracted to
other women actually i actually decided
to go online and say why is it that
sometimes when i'm doing the deal i
think only of myself and that's how i
came to the discovery that autosexual
was even termed your brain's gonna sit
there and think wow i'm am i full of
myself and it takes that sitting down
and saying no because i don't care what
other people think of me
okay
all right well uh can we stop
oh i was doing that a long time ago all
right listen i don't know what's going
on all these new sexualities hey maybe
it's a good thing maybe it's a bad thing
i don't know honestly i just i roll at
the hall of it and i'm like whatever
just don't talk to me about it because i
don't give a [ __ ] not that deeply
anyways so
maybe i'm just not ready to learn about
this stuff maybe it's gonna be my kids
generation or come out with you know bat
sexuals and
trisexuals and all these new sexualities
that i'm just going to roll my eyes at
you maybe i missed the boat did you say
bat sexual
batman
i don't know [ __ ] me you're laughing
but i'm not even 20 years ago did you
think we'd be here i'm not even laughing
okay
hey listen anything can happen that's
what i realized there's new sexuality
for everything so i can't wait for
currency sexual to be mainstream because
that's fire i'm trademarking that i came
up with that yeah let us know what you
guys transitionalism that's yeah is